[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the fabled prophecy and what
is arguably the most important date in
harry potter law as a whole
and that is the day that lord voldemort
traveled to godric's hollow to murder
the potters
most of you probably know why voldemort
traveled there on that fateful night to
kill baby harry but what some of you
might not entirely understand is why it
had to be done
why did he have to kill the potters
wasn't he the all-powerful dark lord
with legions of followers what immediate
threat did this family pose to him the
answer to this question lies inside of
the famous prophecy
the prophecy of course refers to the
prediction foretold by sybil trelawny in
hogsmeade pub in the year 1980
we know sybil as the professor of
divination at hogwarts and we know that
she has a track record of successful
predictions predicting at the end of the
93-94 school year that pettigrew would
escape and that voldemort would return
however she was not always so successful
and in 1980 found herself in the
hogsmeade pub with dumbledore
interviewing for her post as professor
while her poor reputation preceded her
dumbledore gave her a chance because she
was the great granddaughter of famous
seer cassandra tralani
during her interview a disappointed and
unimpressed dumbledore began to lose
interest when suddenly sibyl entered
into a trance in her trance-like state
sibyl spoke of the famous prophecy that
we all know
explaining that voldemort would be
defeated
it spoke of a boy that would be born at
the end of july that possessed the power
to defeat the dark lord himself
what dumbledore and civil did not know
however was that snape who was then a
death eater was eavesdropping at the
door
this simple fact immediately placed
sybil in great danger from voldemort and
in an effort to protect her dumbledore
hired her for the position at hogwarts
the entire prophecy is as follows the
one with the power to vanquish the dark
lord approaches
born to those who have thrice to fight
him
born as the seventh month dies
and the dark lord will mark him as his
equal but he will have power the dark
lord knows not and either must die at
the hand of the other for neither can
live while the other survives the one
with the power to vanquish the dark lord
will be born as the seventh month dies
what's interesting about snape
eavesdropping is that he did not hear
the prophecy in its entirety and only
told voldemort what he remembered
because of this he missed out very
important details like the fact that
harry would be marked as his equal and
that he would possess unknown power
snape also almost immediately regretted
his decision to tell voldemort as he
quickly realized that it would place the
life of lily evans the only girl he ever
loved in jeopardy severus snape had gone
down a dark path and he was a death
eater but he'd also always been
infatuated with lily harry's mother and
actually took action to protect her from
voldemort's attack on the potter
residence
he knew that he would have to do
something if he wanted to save her life
and with nowhere else to go snape turned
to his enemy at the time
the leader of the opposition
albus dumbledore well severus what
message does lord voldemort have for me
no no message i'm here on my own account
snape was ringing his hands he looked a
little mad
with his straggling black hair flying
around him i i come with a warning no a
request
please
what request could a death eater make of
me
the
the prophecy the prediction trelawny
ah yes said dumbledore how much did you
relay to lord voldemort everything
everything i heard said snape that is
why
it is for that reason
he thinks it means lily evans
the prophecy did not refer to a woman to
dumbledore it spoke of a boy born at the
end of july you know what i mean he
thinks it means her son
he's going to hunt her down
kill them all
if she means so much to you said
dumbledore
surely lord voldemort will spare her
could you not ask for mercy for the
mother in exchange for the sun
i have
i have asked him
you disgust me said dumbledore and harry
had never heard so much contempt in his
voice snape seemed to shrink a little
you do not care then about the deaths of
her husband and child
they can die as long as you have what
you want snape said nothing but millie
looked up at dumbledore the snape was a
desperate man and at this point in time
would have done anything to protect the
woman that he loved lily evans snape
told dumbledore that he would do
anything to ensure that lily was
protected and this was a testament to
snape's devotion to lily
he dropped his deathy to status and the
life that he'd built for himself in an
instant when he found out that lily was
in danger
however snape's last ditch effort to
protect miley was too little too late
and ultimately proved unsuccessful with
the information that had been provided
to him by snape voldemort came to the
conclusion that harry potter was the boy
that the prophecy was talking about
lily and james potter were some of
dumbledore's most powerful supporters
and integral members of the order of the
phoenix which meant that voldemort
already had them on his radar the snape
who hated james potter vehemently helped
him with this intel
the only other option for a child that
posed this threat to him was neville
longbottom who was born on the 30th of
july but voldemort firmly believed that
it was harry
this brings us to voldemort's next move
partially driven by ignorance and
partially by foolishness voldemort
believed that he would be able to
circumvent the prophecy by murdering
harry on wednesday october 31st
voldemort traveled to the town of
godric's hollow where the potter family
lived it was here that voldemort in an
attempt to murder harry ended up
murdering james and lily voldemort did
not go there with the intention of
murdering harry's parents as to him they
were no immediate threat however they
did get in the way which meant that he
would have to dispose of them he had a
very specific goal and that was to kill
harry when he entered their home he
first ended the life of james potter and
then began making his way towards lily
and baby harry
when voldemort approached lily he asked
her to step aside and let him have harry
to somewhat honor snape's wishes he told
lily that if she stepped aside that he
would spare her life but obviously
lily's main priority was protecting
harry because she would not get out of
the way she was murdered by voldemort's
killing curse
next voldemort turned his wand on harry
he knew that he was moments away from
killing the only boy or wizard that was
a threat to him and his regime however
what would happen next is something that
he never could have predicted as after
firing a killing curse at harry his
curse rebounded back at him
this was the result of a loving
sacrifice that lily had made
sacrificial protection
when the curse came back at him it
destroyed him and it marked the end of
voldemort for a time but it also
tragically marked the end of the potters
this date october 31st marked the end of
the first wizarding war secured harry's
reputation as the boy who lived and
marked the point in which snape's
allegiance completely shifted this was a
prominent date in history as it allowed
the wizarding world at least for a time
to get back to normal
during the first wizarding war voldemort
really peaked in terms of power
i'm sure he was able to secure followers
and get his body back in the second war
but in the first war he really had a
strong secure confident grasp on the
wizarding world
he knew that he was in control and
everyone else knew it too
that is what makes this date so
important as if the events of this day
didn't occur voldemort's rule of the
wizarding world may have just lasted
forever and that's it for this video
what video do you want next let me know
in the comment section below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you